while complex fraction is where you have
fractions inside of a larger fractions
so it's like a fraction inside of a
fraction and of course it looks complex
right it's complicated but what we're
gonna do is we're gonna try to eliminate
that so you just have one fraction okay
so to do that there's a couple different
techniques that I think I'm going to
show you in this video is how to clear
the denominators okay so the first thing
you want to do is you want to factor all
the denominators so you can see what
they're made up of so here I'm going to
factor this X plus 1 and X plus 3 so
that gives you 1 X + 3 X which is 4 X
okay so I factored that so the common
denominator out of X plus 1 X plus 3 and
X plus 1 X plus 3 is X plus 1 times X
plus 3 so that would be the common
denominator if you were to like add
these fractions together that would be
the denominator that you would want so
let's go ahead and multiply the
numerator and the denominator okay by
that common denominator now I'm just
putting this over 1 because anything
divided by 1 is itself and of course
anything divided by itself is 1 and
multiplying this whole thing which
represents 1 times this complex fraction
won't change the value of it it's just
going to change the way that it looks ok
so what we're going to do is we're going
to think about distributing I'm going to
take this whole quantity here I'm going
to distribute it to this fraction and
I'm gonna distribute it to this fraction
and over here I'm going to distribute
that to this fraction ok so when I take
this whole quantity I distribute it to
this first fraction can you see how the
X plus ones are gonna cancel one another
out ones in the numerator ones in the
denominator they cancel right so you're
just left with X plus 3 times 3 so let's
write that down here so 3 times X plus 3
there's no denominator because the
denominator cancelled out when we take
this times this fraction you can see
that X plus 3s are going to cancel so
you denominator a numerator and you're
left with X plus 1 times 2 X so that's
2x times X plus 1 all divided by now
we're going to take this
distribute it to the denominator and you
can see that the X plus 1 and X plus 3
are going to cancel because these are in
the denominator these are in the
numerator and we're just going to be
left with 5 so at this point you can see
that we only have one fraction here just
see the one fraction bar so it's we
simplified it we can do a little bit
more work here by distributing okay
combining like terms and simplifying so
let's do that so we have 3x plus 9 minus
2x squared minus 2x we're distributing
the negative 2x okay into the
parenthesis all divided by 5 and let's
see so we've got negative 2x squared
minus 2x and plus 3x is plus 1 X plus 9
all divided by 5 and that's our final
result now I'll just mention to you
sometimes you can factor this further
the numerator and the denominator at
this point and you can see if there's
something that cancels top and bottom so
you want to look for that but again the
key here was to find the common
denominator multiplied to the top and
bottom to clear the denominators let's
look at one more example so this one
here you've got a denominator of X X
minus 1 and this one doesn't have a
denominator so let's just call it over 1
okay
what's the common denominator here can
you can you see it it's going to be x
times X minus 1 that would be the common
denominator so let's go ahead and
multiply the numerator in the
denominator by X X minus 1 here if we
distribute the axes are going to cancel
so we're just going to be left with 5
times X minus 1 in the denominator when
we distribute the X minus ones are going
to cancel we're going to be left with x
times 2 which is 2 X and if we
distribute it to this quantity here that
nothing really cancels out right so
you're just left with 3x times X times X
minus 1 so all we're left with now at
this point is just to do a little bit
more simplifying factor if possible see
if anything cancels out so let's just
get into a little bit of arithmetic here
we've got 5x minus 5 by
here we've got three x squared
distributed gives you three X cubed
that's three x squared minus one which
would be 3x squared times negative one
is negative three x squared plus two X
now we can look at factoring this a
little bit further to see if anything's
going to cancel a numerator denominator
I'll show you how to do that just so you
can see but it looks like this is our
final result let me just double check
here so the numerator you can write as
five times X minus one that's what we
had here I'm just factoring out the
greatest common factor and then over
here looks like we can factor out an X
so we're left with three x squared minus
3x plus two and you could try to factor
this further but it's not factorable
okay so at that point you know you're
done you can have it